je m'appelle Antoine Duval je suis un
Français moyen j'ai 40 ans je mesure 1 m
70 je pèse 80 kilos
je suis fonctionnaire je suis marié j'ai
deux enfants
j'habite en appartement 2 3 pièces que
j'ai obtenu grâce au Crédit Foncier j'ai
souscrit une police d'assurance vie
je n'aime que la cuisine au beurre je
mange du pain d'épices quand je fais
cuire des nouilles à la semoule de blé
dur je les goûte je les goûte souvent je
bois de la chicorée je fais
régulièrement la cureur orange je bois
du jus de raisin je bois du jus de pomme
je fais la pause café je mange du
fromage en portion
enfin je fais tout ce que la télévision
me conseille de faire
et je m'en vais